love does not conquer all okay we have  this romantic notion that love conquers  all if two people truly love each other  respect each other that whatever  hardships are thrown at them throughout  their life their love will be able to  see them through i disagree i think  there are a lot of practical life  factors that however unromantic it  sounds can contribute to a relationship  working out or a relationship ending and  that could be things like distance work  belief systems values sickness it could  be financial people often forget to talk  about money in relationships and that  can cause huge risks love does not  conquer your bank account but ultimately  love is not the same thing as  compatibility and i think compatibility  is something that we have to get like  really honest with ourselves about  [Music]